quella tutti ragazzi minuto questo video
sono fa vice oggi siamo su siamo su
questa roba che credo sia ce l'ha c'è la
mia faccia di sfondo ma come figo
ragazzi siamo su snapshots che è un
applicazione per l'ipad che pavimenti in
questi giorni la mia bacheca di facebook
è piena zeppa di merda su snapshot di
gente che si fa i self icon arcobaleni e
gesù che indico ho detto ma perché non
vediamo che minchia è sta roba
perfetto io non ho manco snapshots deve
fare pure registrare ci siamo ragazzi
fatevi vedere se esco la mia passione
troppo semplice minchia dura era troppo
semplice ho finalmente che bello che la
farcia che ciò fantastico tocca per
farsi una foto si è mio zio che cazzo ci
siamo ragazzi credo che sia così
quindi se io aprì il cazzo pesti rasoi
gillette che non tagliano un cazzo oggi
lo zio favi mi insegnerà come fare i
compiti
passo 1 e basta inizio anche terzo al
bene di dovrei testo molto bello molto
bello e sono più bello come ero prima
che questi pro adesso capisco cosa
provate voi donne quando vi si toglie il
trucco maree fatemi capire che a me è
caduta la sua vena e non mi piaceva
essere al centro dell'attenzione perché
perché praticamente io sono sempre stata
una ragazza timida cos'è
ma sei serio io già già che faccio
pagare di mio mi ha messo ancora più
rosso perfetto quindi posso fare bene
fate provare un altro tipo alza le
sopracciglia
ma che cazzo sinceri e veri temi mi tira
gli schiaffi batti cinque zio ha
funzionato non ha assolutamente senso ma
passiamo al prossimo a oliver dio
ragazzi costa troppo di
oddio foto profilo no kat
beh oddio oddio che cosa bruttissima
parlante che gli occhi cielo quasi io
non so dove cazzo ne li vede ecco cos'è
che ha un po come quando vostra madre vi
dice ordiniamo alla pizza stasera manca
e vabbè faccio così schifo zio
addirittura da scacciare vero ma allora
noi gli diamo scherziamo ragazzi però i
bambini di oggi crescono proprio con la
tecnologia quindi loro sanno di queste
cose e l'asi milano come se fosse reale
ragazzi che se gli avessi un figlio in
questo momento la prima cosa che farei
sarebbe questa
ora lo so io dovrei fare il perbenista e
dire ma non si fanno queste cose i
bambini però io due o tre camion di
medaglia alla madre glielo darei va beh
finiamo l'attimo con snapshots vediamo
se riesco a fare un qualcos'altro di un
po meno ridicolo ok ragazzi sono passata
un qualcosa di un po più ovvio che cazzo
che quando vi si dice ragazzi
innamoratevi dei ragazzi con gli
occhioni
wow no vabbè ragazzini sta inquietando
sta cosa bastia realtà il mio essere
così gran figo no profit giuro che ho
studiato propria guerra di [ __ ] guerra
di [ __ ] è quella che cresce sta su
youporn e giusto stesso mi fa ridere va
frange verso molti mi dicono che occhio
per le donne riesco a vedermi il
cervello è ovvio che strano a dio
oddio cos'è sta roba mi sento in dovere
di dirvi ragazzi che mi sento un po
moscio oggi c'è nel senso mi sono alzato
stamattina è con lunedì mattina io mi
sento così sempre non c'è verso no mamma
non ho bevuto ma niente giuro mi si crea
una pagina in mezzo la faccia ma che
roba
oppure sembra quello delle pringle
quindi ragazzi penso e spero che abbiate
capito che c'è un motivo serio queste
cose in bacheca tipo quando le vedo
lancerei computer c'è un motivo
porca [ __ ] congressi spero che vi sia
piaciuto e che sia stato istruttivo se
vi state chiedendo come faccio a fare
così schifo anche se in questo momento
non ci sono effetti bene questo me lo
sto chiedendo anch'io mi chiedo scusa
ragazzi se questo video durato poco però
diciamo che la più che altro uno sfogo
che volevo fare nei confronti di
snapshot e ste cagate qui però che vi
sia piaciuto è stato è stato più uno
sfogo che altro perché porca mignot ogni
tre secondi vedo robe del genere come se
i ragazzi se vi è piaciuta 120 piace
capace di facebook con la descrizione
chelsea di scrittrici vi diamo prossimo
vi do belle ragazze e attenzione a voi è
chiusa gli arcobaleni perché lo uccido